now when was the last time you went to a
concert or a big event with hundreds of
people
packed tightly into one space that's not
been possible for many of us
due to the pandemic but revelers in one
dutch city
were able to forget about coronavirus
just for one weekend
they took part in a test event run by an
organization that's
looking to see how we can best return to
some sort of normality
while keeping safe arm in arm
face to face for just one weekend in one
park
in one dutch city bidding hazen people
dance
like there's no one watching
[Music]
it feels like before corona like
immediately
in fact plenty of people are watching
doctors government officials and event
organizers
in an initiative called field lab this
is more than a concert
it's part of a series of scientific and
social experiments the aim
to see how people interact when allowed
some freedom from coronavirus
restrictions
everyone here agreed to wear trackers so
that all their moves at the concert can
be recorded
they'll be watching this a little bit
weird but we don't care
it's okay they all tested negative to
get in
and will take another test five days
after the event
if anyone tests positive contacts can be
traced
subhan bhutan is a doctor in a covid
ward
she knows what's at stake here and she's
confident the risks are minimal
everyone here is negative so that's
assuring
yeah partiers are being observed in
their natural habitat
most people here aren't wearing masks
and the experiment requires
that the experts don't interfere andreas
vos is one of the doctors working with
the field lab project
and he admits to being just a little
nervous people are careful at the
beginning and then during the party
it will will be they will be very much
less careful
so we want to have the way they party
usually
because otherwise all the data we would
have would be would be senseless
field lab's peter liubert says he's
confident the data will prove
that with precautions event sizes can be
safely expanded i think we can prove
that we really can increase
the capacity of visitors maybe in steps
maybe starting with 50
go to 70 or 80 percent and in the end we
want to have the
our real goal is to have 100 i really
hope for everybody in the industry it
has been super hard and
yeah that somehow we get out of this as
soon as possible but for now dr voss
says
the party's over we do this to allow
more or to give more possibilities in
the future but at this time
people really should stick to the rules
outside
this pile of events in other words what
happens in bidding hersen
stays in bidding
you